ever wanted to play cancelled saint's  row game now's your chance  well sort of volition cancelled saints  row undercover for PSP back in 2009 but  now you can play the prototype volition  recently handed unseen 64 in ISO of the  cancelled game so you can download it  from there you'll need a PSP emulator to  run it though a modded handheld won't do  the trick  and since volition itself released the  prototype there's no need for concern  this is all on the up-and-up undercover  isn't even the only canceled saint's row  game out there an arcade shooter called  Saints Row money shot was also scrapped  during the Xbox 360s run if you've got  the software in the desire Saints your  undercover is yours to play just don't  expect to find any superhero leaps and  punches in there in the meantime keep  hanging with GameSpot for all the saints  row news you need